The Joe Rogan experience.
I don't know if you knew,
but I used to um,
do tournament fighting a karate style.
Yeah.
Right.
And the reason the,
what discourages me or made me know that I didn't want to be a Friday,
it's just what you described,
anxiety.
Oh yeah.
It would,
it was paralyzing.
Paralyzing.
Yeah.
I mean,
um,
I be frozen with it.
It's,
it's so crazy that I'm going to,
last term,
I was an ed Parker's a international karate championships in Long Beach,
California.
And,
and then he would fight until my feet were stuck and I was a taekwondo black
belt,
but my feet were frozen to the fucking man.
I couldn't lift them.
My next way to thousand pounds eats me.
And I was so paranoid because all these people,
it was people were around and I was so afraid that I was going to do something
to embarrass myself.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
everybody's looking and you know,
I'll sit plenty.
Max is going on at the same time.
But it felt like everybody was looking at me and I'm like,
man,
you to watch me through something.
My techniques could be wrong.
I'm just going to fuck up in front.
End of the fear was paralyzing him.
Like,
you know,
I can't fucking do this.
I'm not cut out to be a fighter man.
I just can't,
the pressure just kicked my ass.
It's a,
it's a hard thing to overcome.
Oh Man.
It's hard to sort your way through it.
And it was really hard for a lot of fighters is coming back from a loss.
They get beat up and smashed and then then they have to come back and figure out
a way through,
you know,
and um,
I see a devastating loss.
Of course she sees him yet,
but devastating.
No,
Raymond Daniels is,
oh,
of course they go.
Did you see his fight?
This,
do you see that seven 20 degree punch Kokoda bellatore that find that clip,
man,
I let,
we won't be able to show it.
Right.
I can show you guys.
Just show us for folks who don't know what the Ro,
one of the reasons I brought up Raymond Daniels is Raymond Daniels.
Oh,
he's a belt or kickboxing champion.
Now he lost in devastating fashion to Nikki hold skin,
who's a,
another world champion.
And also to Joel to Valtellina,
who's another world champion.
So when he was making the transition from karate champion to kickboxing
champion,
he had some stumbling,
didn't,
didn't go 100% smooth,
but that guy has got an iron will
man,
um,
stunt coordinators and move here.
This,
watch this.
Look at Ray Mactan,
Raymond Daniels.
Wow.
That's fucking,
that's fucking crazy.
He went for a three 60 roundhouse kick.
Dude wasn't there.
And then he continued to spin further and boom.
I mean,
that is insane.
That is such an insane,
the land,
a punch at the end of,
I mean,
it is so bananas.
And he landed a spinning back kick to the body right before he did that too.
Yeah.
I mean,
he did a thing,
find the thing he did in,
um,
in,
in glory.
He did a jumping sidekicks,
spinning back kick combination where he touched them.
He touched him with the front leg and then spun in the air and spinning back
kick area is right here.
Yeah.
I mean,
this is fucking crazy.
He,
oh here,
watch,
watch how he does.
Let,
let this go.
Here it goes,
watch he touches it.
[inaudible] be shit and to do worldclass kickbox you're like,
that's what I'm saying.
I mean the,
the move started quarterlies are looking at his highlights.
You go to come up with,
you know,
fight free,
eat their stuff that they don't even do in the movies in a real fight.
Yeah.
He's hard to handle.
He,
he,
I gave her a pep talk or speak them to a group of fighters and he was in the
group that came out here.
I got frank after me.
I'm like,
man,
I don't know.
Oh,
it's a fan.
A fan boy.
Big Term Motherfucker.
I love
watching those guys.
And like guys like Michael Van and Paige was another one who has those karate
skills,
but then they're learning all the skills of MMA and then you see,
look man,
if you don't know that karate style and he knows MMA,
like you're kind of fucked because they do shit that's like outlandish.